[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our posture how did you
get in here there's a locked door how
the heck did you even get in I climbed
up there's a trellis outside it climbed
up a trellis and climbed through the
window I can't be real with you I don't
know what a trellis is oh can you I'm
gonna be real - I'm calling the cops
I'm gonna ask the cop when he gets here
what a trellis is okay
welcome back to the gingely and podcast
and for me is brought to you by the skin
what a great thing the skin is it's a
newsletter it's completely free you wake
up in five minutes you can skim the most
important news with the skin all right
and if you want to deep dive they have
more information for you there go to the
skim comm that's th es ki mmm - MS com /
and drilling into your email subscribers
completely free do it right now it's
awesome and you entered to win a $250
Visa gift card when you do that also if
you're building a website do it with
Squarespace okay Squarespace is an
awesome service they make building
websites super streamlined and easy and
beautiful you can make really
nice-looking websites with little to no
experience at all it's so easy you're
going to be kind of blown away so check
it out you could do a free trial right
now or go to Squarespace comm slash in
and Jillian to save 10% off the first
purchase of a website or domain right
now what he's trying to read the sponsor
whether you had a thought was that I
needed to I'm sorry I tried to wait till
the end well you didn't try that hard
waited as long as I could then I
couldn't wait anymore so what do you got
in that mug there yeah I did pour some
wine and it's 11 a.m. 11 a.m. it's 4
p.m. Oh which means it's 5 o'clock
somewhere
yeah at my house was really like two
hours away from us that's fine I don't
know why I did that I never do anything
like that but I just said I don't know
why I just thought I would do it it's
all good
yes there's wine rose a wine in this cup
Jenna's really psyched right now she's
everything's great mm-hmm okay our
headphones are too loud
mommy's gonna be shouting no your love
shout we just got you over me and Debbie
are we're sharing the same same volume
thing here so I know I'm welcome back to
the podcast appearance Oh what's your
name Oh No is your fifth appearance it
has to be fifth where's our sushi shirt
oh it's the hell you think we're the
sushi shirt the podcast
it's B it's hermetically sealed and it's
being sent off to the Smithsonian why
did you even bring it you said you
brought it on the trip but you don't
doubt that it's in your suitcase yeah
I'm honestly doubting a hermetically
sealed it's going up to the Smithsonian
because it is so famous listen I just do
what the people ask they wanted you're a
woman if you want you to wear it
we're asking where else were the people
it's it's sealed I can't open it I kind
of disagree a little bit how is it on
its way that this is Smithsonian and in
your suitcase here you're here your
options now okay you either go get it
and put it on or I'm gonna go get it and
put it on me that now that I would pay
to see there's no shirt you're supposed
to fight for your shirt and say don't
touch it it's for me you should sell
merch that is sushi shirts that was
Jillian's idea
well Assoc shirt on a she's not a shirt
gallons on the house just send me a free
shoe sheet so this is my sushi shirt and
then why I'm wearing my sushi shirt and
the product description is sushi shirt
shirt what do you think listen if you
want to get going to business I'll shake
it with you why not cuz I'm trustworthy
yeah okay I don't know especially when
you're in that tone of voice that that
means you're on so you're saying my tone
of voice is indicative of what my
trustworthiness is you can't even hardly
keep a straight face I'm not talking
normally I'm talking normally with a
straight face he's
right wrong yeah I could tell when
you're all I can think of when I hear
straight faces Chris is Chris Miller
Gert walk a straight line holding hands
Weiner I can't think straight
yeah anyway see ya it was great to be
here thanks I put him back on see ya
know I was I was only gonna be on for a
few minutes as I knew waiting is like
hello see ya you know how they say oh oh
ha that means good hello and goodbye it
was CEO as like a hello away see ya is
that like in a science way and it's like
in a hello way are you quoting me yeah
because if you're quoting me I'd like
you to properly cite that science way
kind of have some coffee I need more
energy somehow only if you pour it from
up here okay and I'm wearing my new croc
shirt wrists it for the biscuit right
there you know that with your wine do
with your one actually don't have to
need to sure you're gonna get red wine
on it is it red oh no it's white wine
you just drank it normal I don't that
wasn't you that's like you going to a
hot dog eating contest and just eating
one hot dog slowly and believing like
what even was that I'm not gonna drink
that much wine I'll spill it all over
the whole podcast with it for the
biscuit okay no it's daddy daddy I'm not
signing off on Debbie Debbie Debbie do
it do it all right now I'm take no part
in any of that
I wasn't even can you take the marble
bed off the table get it the hell out of
here
marbles in my lap cuz I gave him a bath
so he needs cuddles cuz he's still a
little chilly
he's a fuzzy boy sorry neat dude not
doing your shirt injustice you've been
you've been
that hard anyway the machine is here in
town with us so we thought hey instead
of podcasting and just abandoning her
downstairs why don't why don't you join
us for your fifth appearance I think
it's been four years I am happy to
officially announce this is the fifth
appearance I think and you won't wear
your sushi shirt I can't believe you
know the sushi shirt tell you I I don't
believe that you brought it but whatever
we'll deal with that later
mmm-hmm how are you I'm excellent thank
you what's new with you since you were
here last cuz it's been what ten months
something like that I don't know yeah a
long time no I just work on the podcast
which is very fun and I live in Oregon
and I walk my dog
mm-hmm guilty guilty whatever I'm sorry
Gillies been on one this trip go
upstairs and sit in my mom's room all
the entire Toliver in her crate come
down from maybe for dinner maybe and for
potty time what do you mean if I let her
I mean I'm not the boss of her oh she's
the boss yeah well today you you closed
the door to your room and brought her
crate downstairs so that's the only
reason we've seen her today I know but
she ended up staying down there so I
forgot that was how you that's the best
way to deal with this don't just don't
let her go up there so the only dog that
I've ever met that like right after
dinner she just puts herself to bed
she's like all right [ __ ] see y'all
she's like Benjamin Button I'm going to
bed now is it nighttime when she lunged
for some hot food that fell out of the
pot was cooking it so fast that I
actually like I almost lost that fight
because I was like I'm trying to get the
food before she did and she really
wanted to burn herself on that hot food
she was so quick like some of the Iggy's
you know they're sneaky and then they
pounce kind of like little you know
little cats but they're not she's just
like bulldoze towards like slammed into
the cabinet I know people don't feed her
out of your hand cuz she'll jump for it
him especially were in the park or
something and I'm like they said can I
give retreat oh no that would be okay
do they do it no they take their treat
out of their pocket and try to feed her
out of their way you you're a response
meaning no is no that would be okay
that's a confusing I would definitely
give it to you I say you know thank you
okay
I also think bringing dog treats to a
dog park is just a great way to start a
dog fight anyway that's what I'm like
why have you got anyway I don't go into
that but no thank you
but I when I said was no thank you
what I said what did you say I said no
thank you what that would be okay no
thank you but that would be you know
thank you but right please right now I I
can see I said that now but or I can
hear that I said I know yeah so what
happened can I give you a dog a treat
no thank you okay anyway she just lunges
for it and then she doesn't ever mean to
like hurt anybody but she just she bites
she said she you know she also kissed
bites like when she goes to kiss you
she's got full teeth in there oh yeah
I'm a terrible dog bomb no you're not
she's my daughter she just has a loud
personality I'm just I was thinking is
funny because she's just been completely
on on this whole trip yeah and but you
know she's she's good and what's great
is like she uh she comes over and even
before bunny and now with bunny she
comes over you know however many times a
year we see her and she just fits right
in and she's good with the dogs and
she's easy she you know pretty much
takes care of herself
she's completely I mean not to be rude
but I don't think she needs an owner
apartment by yourself
and just like feed herself a
shopping-center bills up on autopay
should be fun get her some amazon fresh
berries totally fine
well that's what I used to say about
this one just give her food clothing
shelter food clothing shelter and love
and get the hell out of her way out of
her way that's what I used to pull them
up an agenda yeah so I guess I raised
the dog the same way I don't I don't
know no you doing a good job when I was
talking today and I'm thinking about how
just I don't like this is my first dog
the first time I ever owned a dog and
you know when I was turning
the trainer was training me to train my
dog I didn't even know that until after
a while in you know so I can see all the
mistakes I made but she's a terrier and
she's a girl anyway I thought guilt I
thought it would be a funny idea to have
Debbie machine try to guess the meanings
of some urban dictionary words already
now I know that there is a game like a
physical card game that they sell it
like had it the box looked familiar when
I was looking up online what I do think
the bomb it's actually better to do it
the way we're gonna do it because with
the card game there's a visual component
and we like to keep everything kind of
audio centric on the podcast for those
who may just be listening on their
headphones and not be watching we want
to like you know make sure everyone's
covered here so I Jenna and I compiled a
few terms that we wanted to read to you
and you're gonna give us what you think
they mean and then if you get it right
great and then if you don't we're gonna
tell you what it actually means okay
you don't think I'm gonna get them all
right I did it wrong you got a take
you're gonna run a waterfall someone you
know that's called waterfall you know
that's an urban dictionary turner that's
the first 104 one it's called water
falling when you pour a drink in your
mouth but like a waterfall with space
and okay but if I don't get if I get one
right oh you two guys you guys have to
do some I'll waterfall some of that
water if you if you'll let me at Siri
water okay what it's a waterfall it's
only going one direction there's no way
my spit gets in that um gravity is
helping you there if it hits your mouth
and splashes back damn that's pretty
sick I would like to see that actually
yeah
all right you ready okay seventy-two
what does it mean when that wasn't the
answer
it's not they're not math problems I
haven't even said anything I know I was
I thought I had ESP and I thought I
could know what the question was and I
that's the answer that came to was ESP
stand for this extrasensory perception
yeah she [ __ ] stated to a special
person okay
get cooked what does it mean to get cut
I swear what what you said I could look
some up okay but this is the Urban
Dictionary term no it's not the literal
term it's wasn't mean if I say I got
cooked I just got so cooked don't look
at me don't look at me I didn't put this
one in there that's a two-pronged answer
their addiction is a literally filthy
and we did our best to make these we
there's the filthiest but we didn't get
any filthy ones I just this was cooked
so okay I'm gonna say that your
girlfriend pushed you around see that's
actually not a bad guess that's pretty
close to the actual definition of
getting cooked do you know what the term
cuckold is okay so that's it's a short
version of that what's what's cuckold
that's cuckold mean it means it's very
old term I was like when your wife
controlled everything that you did no
that's a very broad sense of it cuckold
if I'm a cuckold it would mean my wife
or a woman went and like had relations
with another person and I was made to be
the cuckold because I was doesn't also
imply that like you're aware of it yeah
I kind of allow it like I'm a little bit
submissive in in this situation have you
seen the vlog where we went and took
pictures with Santa with Kermit Jenna
went to the mall and got Santa pictures
that was a good example of the
traditional term of cuckold Oh in that
situation I was the cuckold and Santa
was the man yeah that man like wrapped
his arm around me like the picture he's
got like his hand lay on your leg and
I'm just sitting there like I'm just can
I leave and Julian Julian was like santa
[ __ ] to me Santa I'm the cuckold
cameraman cuckold cameraman bad name
called it so in your name what it's my
new band what is it called
cuckold cameraman
okay but in the urban dictionary cucked
means you got [ __ ] over like it's
something bad happened like oh I just
got so cooked yeah that seemed like the
answer but I just wasn't at all yeah you
were honestly I was not gonna say that
basically well you you fight that urge
fight the urge to not say something and
just go ahead and say it because that's
your best chance at getting even this
one is saying Julian Julian it's
probably what I'm not gonna answer it no
no this one this one I actually did not
know what it meant before I looked it up
it was one of those like pop-up trending
ones on Urban Dictionary it is called a
a full on Monet mmm this one's actually
kind of mean but I looked at uh you know
it was trending so a full on Monet what
is it why would you call someone a full
on Monet I mean you have to be kind of a
mean person to use this term so I would
say that that means that the person is
sort of round okay and voluptuous okay
so I guess yeah go ahead is that
somebody that wears a lot of makeup or
you could say they went full on Monet on
that face you know what I'm saying
you're both in a weird way you know
getting there the answer is someone
who's attractive from afar but when they
get close oh no it's not the case oh no
oh no it's kind of mean it's kind of a
mean oh no it's a mean time guys you
ever seen a Monet up close makes no
[ __ ] sense
oh boy full-on moaning oh great okay
this one's good you ready yes I'm not
sure what's happening here it was a
choice we're just it's a choice it was a
choice where's my choice this is just
what's happening we're just Nick that's
our brains all right now by the way okay
ready Debbie now you know why I'm day
drinking what is it
and we're that insufferable yo no I
meant you might as well go away listen
all right everyone quiet on set what's
that what does this mean when your dank
RuPt dank drop dank RuPt de bankrupt
like bankrupt
I think yeah I got that right what do
you got dang corrupt um I can give you
it to you in a sentence if it helps oh
sure okay hey we need to hit the weed
spot dog we dank Rob I got no weed man
that's it nice job well done all right
you got one I live in Oregon where it's
legal so there's a lot of stone people
walking around in other places that
people you get you live in Oregon all
right you're cooler than us we get it
you have trees outside people ride their
bicycle as long distances mostly a free
public transportation and everywhere is
dog friendly we get it your crops are
really doing well because it rains a lot
we get it people own like cows and
chickens and Subarus and it's Subarus we
get it you know what they say about
California I'm not I can't represent
Oregon because you know I haven't lived
there very long but they're like oh that
guy's an [ __ ] oh wait there's
California plates on that car no wonder
they're an [ __ ] I think that's
accurate yeah I mean it's also like
there's how many times more people that
live in the state of California than the
state of Oregon so 38 more times
yeah there's a big high possibility of
some of those people gonna be [ __ ]
all right dead-ass tired
no dead asses I mean tired you want me
to give it to you new sentence don't you
be it's not dead-ass tired that sounds
sounds like you could work that's what I
okay give me it give it to me in a
sentence please so Jenna tell me a fact
that would shock
you cut the cameras dead-ass okay that's
good
oh that's like quoted blac Chyna okay
cut the cameras that ass says like right
now
no but like if Jenna said or your ass is
grass if I didn't know you were coming
yeah and Jenna said oh yeah my mom's
coming over I would be like dead ass
dead ass machines coming dead ass good
ass like I don't know get really yeah
yeah like for real like I say dead ass I
mean like are you serious
cut the cameras really cut the cameras
for real I got not oh I see okay yeah
good job you're doing well this one's
actually funny and I didn't know what it
meant you got that you got that one dead
ass you got that one dead ass hit me up
hit me up come on taps me thank you okay
this one's Nebu arey never weary it's
funny never weary that's why I said now
if you weary Nebu arey Nebu arey
yes that's what it snows in February
what no that would just be called snow
in February no it's because the word in
Spanish for Nebu arey
Oh like never yes never be damned earth
for something that will never happen
yeah like oh yeah I'm definitely gonna
come over to your house on Nebu arey
24th yes I like that one too I actually
felt good I'd use that one yeah like I'm
never weary coming on this podcast
[Laughter]
well you know listen all right
what oh nothing no no no go ahead
that is us
do you know what we're getting these
from out of your butts I don't know the
urban dictionary verse I know what it is
it's an online thing that says what what
there's a website and if you want to
build a you build it with Squarespace so
if you want to build your version of
Urban Dictionary but better or your own
or nothing to do with Urban Dictionary
squarespace.com slash annejulien
dead-ass okay use that URL it's linked
below if you do that you get 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain it's a drag-and-drop
visual website builder it makes it so
simple like you're a toddler playing a
little game with their blocks it's so
easy fresh and responsive I added it
it's edited in there's easy interfaces
to use for your podcasting website you
can have an online shop it can be for
photography it can be for your small
business whatever it is you can do with
Squarespace and if all that isn't enough
if you ever need help they have 24 hours
a day 7 days a week customer support
award-winning customer service on
Squarespace so if you ever get stuck or
you want to learn how to activate
different features or make a website
change that you don't quite know how
they are there to help you literally all
day and all night which is amazing so
you can add your content in the way you
want it to look on mobile on desktop on
iPads on tablets whatever
Squarespace build the website of your
dreams with Squarespace okay
do it right now and go to Squarespace
calm slash energy only to save dead-ass
10% off your first purchase of website
or domain or click the link down below
and while we're clicking links check out
the skim over 7 million people wake up
to news that is summarized for them in a
concise newsletter known as the skim I
do it I love it
it is one of the few very few emails
that I actually click on in my inbox
nowadays where it gives me a nice
concise rundown of what's going on in
the world without any of the nonsense
mumbo-jumbo that I don't want to sift
through they've already done it they can
it's it's so beautiful and easy to read
it's just like having a snack but the
snack is information and right now you
go do the skim calm th tsk I mmm that's
two M's enter your email and click
Subscribe
completely free and check it out like
test it out give it a give it a little
test drive for like a week
see how you like it the odds are you're
just gonna walk around more informed and
smart and wonderful and educated and
happy so check it I'll go to the skim or
click link down below and when you enter
your email and subscribe you're also
enter doing a $250 Visa gift card that
could be completely free money for you
so give it a shot
thank you sponsors okay this one's good
alligator arms do you know what that
doesn't know okay oh man we've all seen
some alligator arms oh oh it's a very
all right let me I'll give you a hint
it's a very specific scenario that this
word was coined it's not like dead ass
where it can be applied in many
scenarios this is for one situation that
happens that's not what it I don't know
are you like on your stomach and using
your arms like this in some capacity no
our alligators arms long or are they
short they're sure can't reach something
yes alligator
no no that's I'm your warmer warmer gone
yet what you said yeah see I was like I
had alligator arms you can't reach
something you're trying to you oh I
don't know I'm gonna say you can't reach
the cake when you need it very close
it's when someone when you're out to
dinner and someone reaches for the check
the person so it's basically for people
who are flexing to get the check but
they don't actually want to grab oh let
me get that let me get it yeah yeah it
doesn't even go that far though it never
reaches over the table oh you get that
right I got whoo whoo whoo
eww eww you
Oh eww you you won't you okay no
incorrect yeah I can tell mom oh my
don't you want to know all right I'll
give you this it's not an echo oh is
that like um you look great
ooh whoa sort of it means cuteness
overload so if you see something really
cute it makes you Hulu what does it
looks like a cat when you write it out
right Jenna
yeah like the W is a little M okay this
is another one I didn't know but I
actually think it's kind of funny that
they made this a definition bTW oh
you're not gonna guess it if you don't
know it's very random but give me your
best shot
mmm beat the others no I'll give you a
hint
what does PT I mean paid time off
mmm-hmm
bed time off nope Beauty time off nope
best time off no banana time off okay
that's it it means bathroom time off
somewhere to paid time off or personal
time off one can easily achieve 40 hours
of additional vacation time by taking
daily 9:23 day daily 9.20 three-minute
dump at work executive types and
employees with seniority can often
increase their BTO up to 60 hours a year
by extending their bathroom sessions to
thirteen point eight five minutes I can
see why you don't think that was funny
what it's funny that's what I think
here's that you know I would not have
thought that sentence I think you need
to hear it sure damn I got to level 168
on candy crush this year just on BTL
along that's pretty good a BT oh okay
drip
so drip is like it's coming so are you
you're making are you making me a drink
drip no no it's not that
well drip used to be like somebody who's
a real like loser a drip was somebody
draw like you're being a total drip yeah
a drip was thank you for that
yeah that's old-fashioned that's
apparently not it either is it used as a
noun or a verb or an adjective right
adjective like someone's outfit is a lot
of drip oh yeah mm-hmm
Sam Debbie that sushi sure has some drip
it's got some stylee you respect the
drip pretty much yeah style right yeah
kind of it the actual definition isn't
one year excuse me I'm trying to read
stop having fun over there when your
bling is iced out but that shirt melting
from all your hot bars you got the drip
pretty much what you said mmm
respect the drip when actually I should
amend this no I was gonna say sushi sure
but it says [ __ ] not sure it so it
wouldn't work okay next one vibe check
do you know what vibe check means I
would say that when you're with somebody
you're doing a vibe check to make sure
they're in a good mood because otherwise
you're gonna go home or go somewhere
else pretty much yeah allow it Wow
basically it's like yeah at a random
time someone you're with can check your
vibe by saying five provide Carmy I do
it's a karmic credit rate and he never
passes the vibe check yeah vibes are way
off my
his vibes are off Bob check Debbie
happy good - Pastor Bob check except
it's up to me uh I'm doing the vibe
check so no matter what you say I just
get to read the vibe and I even if you
say I'm good I could be like now you
passed you failed the vibe check Who am
I
you're Kermit mm-hmm now my past the
vibe check vibe Jai guru me Gor me okay
ready hmm Rory
oh it's car my rari is outside no thief
what kind of car kind of hurry yeah she
making a fool out of us do what tow him
say it
do it to him do it to him say you know I
had to do it to him you know I'd do it
to him Thanks okay ready
tall boy oh I have one of those in my
family yeah you do it's a tall guy no no
so a tall boy in my you know back when
Abraham Lincoln was alive a tall boy was
a very large was a big beer so it was a
big can of beer or a big like a GQ or
salute yes that's exactly that's what it
is how many ounces 32 180 180 ounces of
a beer yeah officer I just had one beer
24 ounces what that doesn't sound like a
tall boy to me a regular beer 16-ounce
is the one that's this size and then the
tall boy 24 ounces oh yeah but back in
the day a tall boy was like a tall boy
like a mug no it was like a they have
you know how daddy's kids are like
Chucky Anik yeah that's what it's all
boy is have you seen in Tecate those
come in the big old yeah it fosters and
stuff yeah yeah yes that's only 24
ounces oh no it's bigger than that then
it's not back in the day that is nice
giant Imperial courts do you have those
still I don't know Rock yeah had a giant
imperial court was a big war quar TZ
like the rock court Giants GI q giant
imperial court was a great big thing of
beer you called a beer a giant imperial
court yes because that was the container
that he came okay that sounds like
something I am I can't talk right there
okay never heard of that yo bartender
another GI q for the table four straws
yeah fishbowl
o is where everybody kind of drinks out
of the sea yeah you'll take strong what
they were drinking out of in the theatre
the night that uh it's been so long they
were sharing a GI q with Debbie Rosie
oak I have some okay BYO West been going
strong when the GI cues in the house
you'd be y ou s dead ass yesterday
thirst trap sorry I missed that
first trap hmm pretzels peanuts salty
chips no oh
a thirst trap do you want to help her
out on this one going someplace where
there's not gonna be anything do you
know it like being thirsty is online oh
yeah what does that mean online hmm
thirsty means you I mean it's kind of
like right here but I don't know look
you like you really want attention from
somebody oh I see yeah you're thirsty
right right right right
so what was our thirst trap we mean like
somebody who's very needy kind of like a
woman that's very needy
a seller's thirst trap is like a post
usually with a photo of oneself that is
specifically posted to garner attention
of the sexual nature often from Simpson
it's a trap but it's a trap because
you're actually not getting your thirst
quenched for that person it is an
illusion it is a game of a play that
likes and numbers there's treasure ship
or DMS or attention I don't know there's
many uses for a thirst trap kind of like
potato chips but not really yeah it's
like the online version meant potato
chips okay head ass
okay so there's dead ass dead ass head
ass mmm so if dead ass means if Kermit
were to run outside barking in attack
opossum in the in the bushes and really
be a nuisance I would say babe Kermit's
being a head ass hmm that's kind of my
example mmm it's cuz he's got his head
up his ass but that's not mm-hmm that is
literally what it is I thought is that
where he came from head up your head up
your ass
well yeah but it's also like yeah it
attacks a person person's intelligence
so if you call someone a head after
basically calling them stupid mmm head
up head ass yeah your heads up your ass
right yeah mm-hmm
say it call me you hit us Oh kids can
you be a head ass dead ass you being a
head ass that ass fantastic Oh
dead ass call me with that one I'm dang
Crupp to drink
okay but the wine oh no drinking no I
can't flex wine and then not drink it
places wine doesn't drink what a friend
drinking wine that ask any of it dead
ass that's you're gonna pour that wine
or not drink it I'll put it in the
refrigerator oh that's ma
s MH my head said yes mhm
I missed that did you drink out of it
yeah you hand it yeah III waterfall bit
okay good for him
come on machine no we didn't have any on
you I was yeah practice round was
earlier she's had it with us yeah just
push through okay God Church what's a
God Church
what's a guide Church mmm
Oh synagogue no oh this is urban
dictionary yeah Oh God Church um that
would be a building that's not a church
but where people go and have a good time
have you ever heard um Jake Paul's song
is everyday bro
no have you really I don't think so are
you sure that one of the like five
billion views it has isn't yours
probably not okay
here I'll put it in a sentence for you
okay machine just dropped those sushi
shirts shirts and they're selling like a
god Church oh yeah like hotcakes yeah
that's a hotcakes like wildfire
the actual definition not my words
gotcha is some stupid [ __ ] Jake Paul
said that's referring to the song it's
everyday bro because he says my merch is
selling like a God Church that's why I
said that Jake pause right I get it okay
Stan Stan Stan yeah that's when you like
someone you're in a relationship with
them well what was the second thing
you're in a relationship with them well
usse well it could be in a relationship
in your mind okay you know you're not
really in a relation with them but you
you wish you were or you're you stand
somebody you like them yes you know oh
no I don't Eminem song man do you
remember that song Oh Stan oh yeah
he's reading the letter yeah oh yeah oh
okay I didn't know that yeah all right
copped well in the olden days cop cop
meant - that won't be talking john
wilkes
cop meant to steal something or grab
some so used it in a sentence so
somebody would you know like a cop like
and you're in your uniform
you just yeah somebody cops so like say
I owe I copped some cigarettes at the
store
yeah that's literally yet you claim
property oftentimes someone else's yeah
I caught that from somebody or if like a
new pair of dope sushi shirts come out
sushi shirt shoes yeah like yeah I cop
those sushi shirt shoes it's just a
picture of your sushi shirt on the shoe
no but she sushi shoes it's like looks
like a piece of sushi except it's a shoe
they're probably out there don't you
I've never been to Japan but don't you
think it's a probably okay snack
oh that's somebody who looks cute yeah
she's owning she's like doing so well
but you had to tell me the first fifty
you're doing to be honest all right
speaking cursive oh I like that one
to be incomprehensible that's not an
accurate yes it's a characteristic of it
but you're you're just you know your
when's a time than you that you speak
incomprehensibly know what happens if
you drink a bunch of those glasses of
wine oh when you're drunk yeah yeah he's
talking seeking cursive or you're
chatting or you're trying yeah that was
trying to sing a certain way yeah that's
yeah that would be me yeah cursive sound
yeah I basically talk cursive most of
the time don't a todos
yeah I mean I sing a lot okay
no one lists care to give us a song sure
[Music]
mmm here's what my grandson and I like
to sing he tells you to stop but he does
tell me with a big hand you know right
in my face it's that you know what
should we sing yeah I don't know I can't
think of anything to say
standing ovation what a performance
but let's just say this so Julian made a
space burger I did out of heart pieces
yeah the old acrylic paint that I peeled
off the trace and I turned it into a
space burger and so I put space burger
to the gold finger theme song singing
space burger dad it's a burger that's
made out of pain yep Curtis that was it
right there
dropping on iTunes this week y'all
thanks for coming to promote the new
album all right
stream sniping that's when you go on
someone else's stream and you try to
steal their followers or they're people
that like their stream that's not a bad
guess that's a lotta bad yes I mean
you're that's in essence what people are
kind of doing is trying to steal
attention from ya stream sniping is when
if I'm playing the same game as a
streamer I load up and try to queue into
the same match that they're in and like
use the information watching to go try
and kill try to unfairly kill them yeah
so it's like screen looking but online
yeah that low latency low lanes it's
toxic
you shouldn't stream sensation do it
it's no fun well you should also not
call stream sniper like a lot of people
will die you're like oh yeah sometimes
that person isn't yes right and that
person looks it's a good excuse okay
send what does it mean full send full
send means that you it's kind of like a
full stop
only it's instead of stopping it's like
Oh everything I'm sending everything so
I don't like you so I'm throwing all all
your junk out on the lawn you full send
all like if I if I was gonna take my
motorbike off some jumps into a back and
do a back from the full set full [ __ ]
so you don't have pass something you
just [ __ ] right yeah yes end yeah so
you're gonna start using that word yeah
yeah yeah yeah full send life man
absolutely
oh yeah it was a sushi shirt on top baby
okay cut up with the sushi shirt
speaking to the t-shirt I'll stop
talking about your sushi shirt when you
stop singing things like Goldberger she
calls them original covers okay visco
girl VI SEO with es co v SC o visto girl
how can it be v s o v SC oh sorry it
starts sorry yes you know that would be
someone who likes brandy how did you get
there well I was thinking about that
thing on the on the bottle it says vs on
the bottle on the brandy bottle yeah
I don't drink brandy sorry Tommy what
are you talking about I'm not sure it's
not the real correct answer no oh okay
so vsco she can't know it's very
specific it's hard I can't she can't
like logically guess not
so the definition is the tumblr girls of
2019 you'll probably catch them wearing
a scrunchie tube top
puka shell necklace remember those puka
shells yeah white vans and don't forget
the hydro flask it's like a look it's
like a type of vibe that's
that's visco visco girl okay a lot of
people know you know the house the name
of a photo app yeah disco Kim what's
very weird is follow me on this girl by
the way I've been posting their what's
very weird is that scrunchies tube tops
they would be kids instead of vans
uh-huh or Birkenstocks it says
Birkenstocks right mm-hmm that's what
the old one yeah so it's sort of like a
hipster like bringing back old trans
that's like bringing me back yes Lucas
y'all necklace that was my childhood I
mean I wear those in middle school but
they also have a 70s that's what they
had in the 70 that you had tube tops and
fashion is a cycle it's cyclical it
didn't look good back then either in the
same my mom called y'all [ __ ] and
everyone everyone do with the 70s is
dead ass according to the Demi
well thanks boomer yeah whoa okay this
is my self not to you this is the last
one okay okay I'm ready
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] give me
a break oh I don't think you are I was
eating it what do you think that means I
think that means you better not talk to
me that way because I in your [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
Oh - Ted asked that ass made me a head
ass okay this is an obnoxious Punk and
yes huge coward piece of [ __ ] that
doesn't accept any responsibility
basically like what she just said
yeah like [ __ ] you but this is what I'm
gonna call you it's a it's pretty
straightforward
I just want to end with an easy way ya
know like that was good you get some
momentum into the rest of the day you
know what I mean yeah are you gonna
drink the wine no gold in there touch
touch Chuck I'm not Hank hey Frank tank
Frank that's me Frank the tank yeah old
school welfare oh no oh no yeah I did
watch that but he meant oh yes what you
say that the dog treat at the park oh no
no that's okay but thank you you can
thank you all right that's okay
you can't thank you all right that's
okay yes no yes no it's clarified a lot
for me my let's go watch old school yeah
that clarifies for me why when I say no
thank you
they're still giving it to her cuz I'm
saying something there's probably okay
say nothing to me as the test just go
say say no thank you
oh no thank you see if you said that I
would be unmistakeably completely aware
that you said no no as an answer I have
this feeling that it's not coming out as
clear as it is right now because that's
why I said I just realized that I think
I'm saying instead of just saying no
thank you I'm saying something beyond
that it's just not right
dead ass dead ass it's my own doing well
Debbie we appreciate your company and
time on the podcast I think everyone
else really enjoys you being on here too
so thank you for joining yeah another
podcast of ours it's been an honour
dead-ass we should close with that um
tick tock of grace oh this I just want
to hear the audio anything you have to
promote new album Odin book tours or
what are you promoting
I don't know collabs what do you got
going on
the dog taking a walk take us out for
another episode of
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]